[Musique]
jerry lewis excusez nous de toute façon
nous allons vous parler français
on vous a réveillé ce matin aucun paris
15e téléphonez non je dormais pas couché
tard en ce moment gros l'intérêt pouvait
pas savoir
vous travaillez pas tu me convenait
aussi travaille beaucoup oui et vous
savez oui ça va merci la content de vous
voir les avis moi aussi j'aimerais bien
faire deleware tf1 je reviens écoutez
vous êtes en train d'enfer je fais de la
rtf oui je ne savais pas une scène
ouverte et au café pour et pourtant vous
n'êtes pas de gérer lewis a pas du tout
nous mais jacques dynam mais la voix
française de jerry lewis disent on vous
doublez jerry depuis longtemps depuis
qu'il fait du cinéma depuis environ 22
ans
oui alors vous êtes de vieux compère
finale match aller - comment apprend
t-on à doubler jerry lewis
ben on apprend à chasser on le fait
c'est tout mais vous avez la même voix
que lui au du tout les eaux vous devez
pouvoir vous en rendre compte et les
nattes et les notes dpn big boss de
frein d'offres de france public des like
jerry les français jury
merci
marseille fra - je la monte et où le
faible montant b nous serons sûrement de
g2 au monde voulait s'était passé neuf
mois molex
[Rires]
[Musique]
quand
ah ah
[Musique]